[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
malgré ce que sony jo
ajustera rebelles avancent les pandas
zahia mer
il ya bien des phares ya bien des phares
ya un effort
in show
chance noir et but que ce grand fou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'il soit l'ogm au chili continue comme
ça je viens
[Applaudissements]
ja vichy
[Musique]
à soyaux
noir et blanc
la lumière
je vois dieu
les
oui oui
non
oui là
là
toi
[Musique]
tu
des fois
khadir
[Musique]
applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
non
merci féraud comment ça va être une
autre commerçante et la romance coûteux
qui douves aussi gentil je me demande si
tu as vraiment lorsque tu dis avoir
parce que y'a cli vieux qui arriva mais
là c'est pas possible ce que tu fous ça
va je pas temps de q1 une demi heure on
a cessé au sauna je rappelle qu'on a des
rendez vous à l'elysée à 19h et brigitte
macron pour à l'elysée les livres et les
fromages de chèvre et bas mais avant ça
on sera jamais venu
[Musique]
c'est malheureux qu'un aréna
chanter la romance et pilotis vient
m'agacer avec ses fromages nos chaînes
confondues
[Applaudissements]